well did you know that we're in the
midst of cuffing season and in case you
don't know that's a period of time where
single people begin looking for a
short-term partnership to pass those
colder months of the year and some of
these singles are finding these matches
through music
the connection that I felt to music was
so palpable it just grew into a passion
all of Rachel van nortwick's closest
relationships are centered around people
she's met through music she created a
dating app to connect others who are
also passionate about it and there's so
many people who music is like a deal
breaker for you know it's either their
Identity or they just want to know they
have somebody that can share in
something that's you know so important
and personal to them the app is called
vinylink it's got tens of thousands of
users across the U.S and Canada its
usage peaked during covid and now that
we're in the midst of what's considered
cuffing season coughing season is named
after the idea sort of handcuffs
um you know in the sense that you know
over the summer right it's really you
know sort of more about meeting new
people during sort of the colder months
and approaching the holidays
um you know you sort of want to be like
attached to someone because the
Gatherings are more intimate finding
that perfect match through music is
picking back up once again again van
nortwick says the app is all about
someone's music DNA coming through
having your music make your match for
you here's how it works we take your
Spotify listening data as well as asking
you a few questions about how important
music is to you the role music plays in
your life and then we have a proprietary
algorithm that then produces matches
cupping season we're told typically
begins in October and lasts until just
after Valentine's our web team found a
cuffing season r b party at the House of
Blues scheduled for later this month